tips on slowing down and having well
thought out responses when speaking
publicly
um
the thing that will fix your public
speaking
i would do two things first is record
yourself and watch yourself
you'll see very clearly what your flaws
are i say uh and i pause too much for
and i use filler words too much for no
reason so that's mine at least i'm aware
of it so it's not as bad as it used to
be
the other thing is
know your subject cold and then
don't rehearse don't practice i don't i
don't come on here with any agenda or
anything that i want to tell you or any
specific thing that i refer to talk
about if i did then i would be busy
trying to remember that and i would be
kind of lost
trying to kind of make an argument
but if you know
your subject then you just talk you just
talk like you talk to a friend you talk
like you talk to a colleague you just
talk
when i'm public speaking like right now
i'm hearing my words pretty much at the
same time as you are you've got a little
latency because of periscope but i don't
know what's coming out of my mouth until
it comes out of my mouth
[Music]
you